we're gonna make our infrastructure
modernized and we're really way behind
schedule we're way behind other
countries we always led the way for many
many years then a number of decades ago
it slowed down this is a common-sense
and bipartisan plan that every member of
Congress should support a word that
describes so much of the president's
bill probably about 80% of it is Trump
tolls the Trump infrastructure plan is
like a Hollywood facade it may look real
from afar but in truth it's a flat
Mirage Democrats responding in unison to
the infrastructure pitched by the
president the administration Bernie
Sanders senator from Vermont
saying the Trump budget is morally
bankrupt bad economic policy it pays for
his tax breaks for the rich and large
corporations by slashing Medicaid by 1.3
trillion cutting Medicare by 54 554
billion and slicing 10 billion from the
Social Security disability insurance
program if you look at the budget
highlights came out today we mentioned
the infrastructure 1.5 trillion and then
national defense 716 billion 23 billion
on border security 17 billion on the
opioid crisis but a lot of talk about
what it doesn't do and about long-term
deficit and debt concerns let's bring in
our panel Steve Hays editor-in-chief of
The Weekly Standard Molly Hemingway
senior editor at the federal Federalist
and former Maryland Democratic
congresswoman Donna Edwards we welcome
here Steve let me start with you this
rolled out obviously the president said
this is infrastructure week he's trying
to pitch this does it go the full
distance no I don't think it does I mean
we've had infrastructure weeks before we
haven't had much success part of that I
think is the way that the president has
chosen to talk about infrastructure in
the past rather than emphasizing
deregulation and getting rid of permits
which the White House is doing more this
time they've talked about it as
necessary stimulus and they've
emphasized the the spending aspects of
that well that's not something that's
going to appeal to Republicans in the
House of Representatives and I don't
think it ought to appeal to Republicans
in the House of Representatives this is
going to be a very tough sell for the
president on the infrastructure package
alone I can't imagine it goes anywhere
Molly there's a smart way to do
infrastructure
there's the typical way we do
infrastructure the typical ways that
you're just handing out money to
corporations I mean we saw in the
stimulus bill that it was a lot of
shovel-ready projects that just went to
corporations that were able to spend
money but didn't really do a lot to
change the infrastructure Jim Manzi is a
is a policy analyst who has done good
work on how to do a smart infrastructure
spending where he talks about the
importance of coming up with projects
that help regional or national interests
and can enable private wealth generation
as opposed to just being again these
handouts so we I think we have a lot to
learn about this infrastructure bill and
how much it how much it goes from the
normal way of doing it to to this better
way of doing it but in general this is a
budget that just is irresponsible in how
it doesn't take our debt and deficit
problems seriously and it's it's very
disappointing to see the infrastructure
question for Democrats I think this
administration really would like to have
Democrats sign on to some of this on the
issue of infrastructure listening to
Chuck Schumer and others today it
doesn't seem like they're that close are
they well I think there's a real reason
for that and typically infrastructure up
until recent years has actually been
quite bipartisan here's the problem with
the president's proposal one we have an
infrastructure deficit of about four and
a half trillion dollars this is 1.5
trillion it privatizes a lot of what
should be public infrastructure whether
it's on transit or on highways and and
roads and of course it you know we know
that it has to be it has to be paid for
so it can pay us back and you know the
reality is is that you know with all of
the talk of the investment in
infrastructure 1.5 trillion is actually
about the same amount is that text bill
it would have been actually better spent
on infrastructure I'm not just sure
where it's going to come from and and we
shouldn't be privatizing our
infrastructure do you think that
Democrats have found a new love of
talking about deficits and debt that
perhaps was not there in recent years
that there's a more of a concern because
you have this Republican administration
that seems to want to be spending no the
question is what you're spending on and
so for example if we were spending 1.5
trillion on infrastructure on our
highways our bridges our rows
to clear up the the deficit that we have
on spending infrastructure that actually
pays the economy back because it doubles
up on the number of jobs that you create
and in terms of making our economy
actually much more productive and
efficient and so for me it's a question
of spending it in the right kind of way
if you want it to pay back but you're
not just to be clear you're not spending
the tax dollars by giving people their
money back the people are the ones who
earn the money in the first place
they're you're allowing them to retain
more of the money that they've already
earned or in the cases of these
businesses that are helping to grow the
US economy allowing them to provide some
estimates very some of that money back
to their workers to reinvest others of
it to take others of it in profit that's
money that the private sector is
generating in the first place the
government doesn't have a first right to
that money well that may have been true
if 80% of the tax cuts hadn't actually
gone to only 1% of the population and
giving somebody someone a thousand
dollar bonus does not make up for the
dollar or two dollars that they should
have increase in their salaries and you
know we're talking infrastructure here
you know it's really clear the nation's
infrastructure is actually you know
falling apart our roads our bridges all
of it and so if Republicans are really
serious about talking about
infrastructure we have to do things like
think about how we pay for it what about
the gas tax that hasn't been increased
in you know 25 years what about you know
making sure that we you know invest in
our transit systems which are falling
apart and aren't even keeping pace with
the rest of the world yeah Molly
III think that the the thought process
is that on the tax cuts is that the
growth will will really kick into gear
here and we're already starting starting
to see some of that with some of these
companies reinvesting but on the
infrastructure if he wants to get this
done how does he get to the finish line
considering the Democrat pushback
considering the pushback from his own
party on deficits and debt I hope that
there's pushback from his own party on
some of these issues I worried that
there won't be pushback and the thing is
about this that you increased spending
is a tax increase eventually at least
the best way to give people more of
their money back is to cut spending not
increase spending
we're just seeing a lot of
irresponsibility here I get the feeling
though that Republicans just don't feel
like this is a battle they care about
right now you see you know you point out
the hypocrisy of Democrats suddenly
caring about deficits well Republicans
long claimed they cared about these
things and now they actually have the
levers of power and they're not doing
anything that demonstrates that they
actually do to your point President
Trump then candidate Trump and speaker
Ryan before we o 18 trillion dollars
we're going to 21 trillion and
ultimately 24 which is a magic word you
know 24 trillion that's the magic number
that's like the point of no return and
we're there very quickly we're gonna end
up being another Greece and maybe we're
gonna end up being another Detroit
because that's where our country is
going we need proper leadership we have
got to stop spending money we just don't
have we've got to cut spending we got to
get this budget deficit under control
and get this debt under control so Steve
is the Republican Party changing or is
this a moment in time that they're
trying to get something done on a
bipartisan way to then fix it in their
mind later I think the Republican Party
is changing I mean look president Trump
ran for office not talking about debt
and deficits in the way that Republicans
had in the past and you can be cynical
and say that they didn't mean in the
past either he didn't make it a priority
and he argued against he argued against
yes yo get against the Medicaid reform
medicare reform you argued against
touching Social Security this has been
something the Republicans included in
their budgets from 2011 to 2016 and this
this president for the first time since
1976 didn't mention the national debt in
his State of the Union address that
suggests to me it's a problem I was in
there in one of the longer versions of
it it was later taken out but if you're
not talking about it and you're the
president United States you don't care
about it that much